so when you first started directing
is there any project that you signed on
for as an actor
where you found that directing brain
kicking in
more so than ever in terms of
determining whether or not you wanted to
sign on for that project
oh yeah absolutely yeah i don't i can't
say
which one particular but i know that
that that that happens
and there are certain projects
yeah yeah and there are there are
certain projects that you're asked to do
and you think oh god i wish i were
directing this you know like
and then you think and then sometimes
you meet the director and you think
oh boy i really wish i were directing
this you know because this person
doesn't know what they're doing
or or
my god i never could have directed this
this person is amazing um
there was one movie a hollywood movie
that i was asked to do
and it and i said i
just don't think that i know how to do
that
and and i won't tell you what it was i
was asked by the
by the star of the movie to do it and
then the movie ended up
being very successful
and somebody said to me see it was so
successful why didn't you
direct it it was so good why didn't you
direct it i said
it was so good and successful because i
didn't direct it
that's why if i if i
i mean it's just like it doesn't make
any sense that someone would say that
but you know to me you you have to
it's it's good to have the eye of a
director when you're acting because it
challenges
the director you're able to ask all the
right questions
you just have to make sure that you're
not annoying
because it's not your movie i always ask
my colleagues if they have any questions
for the person that i'm lucky enough to
talk to and
one of the hottest topics that was
suggested by the collider staff is they
all want to know what it was like for
you working with michael bay
so i know that you've
already described his process as i
believe manic and
frantic so maybe what would you say is a
con
but also a pro of working that way
especially on a gigantic blockbuster set
like the transformers movies
the the pro the pro is you
you get a paycheck you get a real
paycheck and that's exciting
that's always exciting um
the pro is also you get to go to lots of
different locations where you probably
never go in your
entire life like chicago i'm kidding
but no you know um but then also
i think the another
this is you know the only the best way
to describe it
is steve buscemi who worked with michael
a couple times described it
the best way he goes it's like making an
independent film with a lot of money and
that
is true the the there is what i really
like about michael
is that he loves actors and and he's
very very spontaneous
um you can walk on
to the set and you might have no idea
what you're going to do that day
and that is for some people that's fine
for some people it freaks them out
i i had a great i actually had a really
great time working with him
um he he's super smart
he um the the only
the hard part is sometimes when it comes
to the stunts
um because there isn't a lot of
preparation it can be a bit dangerous
understandable yeah given your
experience on sets like that and also
what you brought up
a little earlier if you did sign on to
direct you know a massive budget
blockbuster what is a quality about your
previous sets that you would want to
bring
to those in order to i don't know make
it the most
successfully creative experience
possible spontaneity
being able to uh and preparation
i really like to prepare i'd like to be
as prepared as possible and then
be spontaneous when i need to be
preparation allows for spontaneity